this is where Amazon plans to build its
African headquarters
the space between the river and the
mountain is of Heavies as of deep
significance for our people today we
find ourselves within a very
technologically advanced Society
we cannot forget our past we cannot
forget where we come from
it is deeply connected with who we are
today
Bradley van sitters is a leader of the
koisan nation
South African tribe that may be the
oldest on the planet with a distinct
genetic lineage that can trace back 130
000 years
like many of those within the khoisan
tribe he is not happy that Amazon is
coming to this particular corner of Cape
Town in the shadow of Table Mountain
the koisan considered this patch of land
squeezed between a bird sanctuary a rail
yard and the Confluence of two rivers to
be sacred it's the site of his people's
first battle with European settlers some
five centuries ago
in 1510 this is where our people came
and defended themselves defended the
children defended also the woman and
also the cattle against the Portuguese
that came here looking for water and
looking for fresh supplies
to Van sitters the efforts to keep the
e-commerce giant out are an extension of
those first battles with European
colonizers the contest with Amazon or
more specifically the developers
building the site where Amazon's
headquarters will ultimately reside is
being largely fought in the courtroom
though
our communities are suffering and
because of your wealth which you feel
acquired we would hope that you could
look at our people kindly
this headquarters that you want to build
we want to tell you not there the
Insiders view is not universally shared
by other indigenous South Africans some
hold that the 4.6 billion Rand River
Club complex eventually meant to house
Amazon and others will bring a valuable
high-skilled jobs to an area where the
unemployment rate sits at approximately
27 percent that's about 10 times higher
than in Amazon's hometown of Seattle
the new headquarters will reportedly
employ 7 500 people
construction of Amazon's future Cape
Town headquarters though continued after
a South African Court ruled in favor of
developers that ruling left those
opposed to the project including members
of the koi and San indigenous groups
awaiting a separate decision about
whether stakeholders were properly
consulted about the building before work
began
this is not just an argument between
jobs and Heritage had it decently Chosen
and listened to what the communities
were saying listen to what the
environmental organizations were saying
the Civic entities were saying and even
this is what the courts were saying that
other construction would have been up
without much controversy what is up now
is has been done without consent for
Amazon this is about more than just a
patch of land the company plans to
launch its online retail business in
South Africa by February of 2023 and the
new campus will be used to consolidate
old and new employees in one building
but the company is growing increasingly
frustrated by the delays it's been five
years since Amazon announced plans to
find a new site and the developer has
been fighting the court battle for over
a year
the developer Lee's Beck Leisure
properties trust said all the relevant
indigenous people were given the
opportunity to have input into the
project culminating in a quote binding
social compact that Incorporated their
feedback
Amazon did not respond to repeated
requests for comment Amazon will have to
seriously consider being part of the
destruction the desecration
transgression of this most ancient
sacred Aboriginal heritage site
foreign